je suis né en 1892 à 40 ans j'ai zagreb
l'an dernier et françoise nous sommes
allés voir le doyen des petits
inventeurs pierre de vitry qui a
plusieurs gros succès à son actif
notamment le pipi nuit du mines
j'ai commencé les inventions à l'âge de
12 ans
donc en moyenne sur l'inventeur dérive
haineuse sur tous les toits des taxis
plus de 60 inventions sont l'oeuvre de
ce chercheur infatigable dont le
registre s'étend du chausse pied à
droite incorporé aux multiples gadgets
motocyclistes dont les usagers de la
route tirerez bons profits et dont les
brevets sont livres pour le monde entier
l'occupation m'avait volé un vélo ont
valu l'oscar avait fabriqué est un beau
chanter placé sous la fiche de sel et
qui traverse alors le plus beau c'est
d'aubert le type s'étend sur le vélo en
voltige il va pas bien loin il descend
aussi sec dans ce domaine de la défense
et de l'antivol
on le voit père de vitry ancien
chauffeur de taxi est réellement passé
mais